[Music]
on this wednesday night it's fight night
in canada
the five party leaders square off in a
debate who's leading the race now
conservatives are consolidating behind
aaron o'toole as the best chance
to beat justin trudeau as the
conservatives put a price on their
promises vicious storms slam southern
ontario the thunder and lightning
started and then downpour the widespread
destruction
the trial into the 2015 paris terror
attacks finally starts
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
it's go time in gatineau quebec tonight
five federal party leaders will go
head-to-head in the first of two
official debates and the stakes couldn't
be higher
good evening and thank you for joining
us new polling from ipso shows the
liberals and conservatives locked in a
tight race what happens in tonight's
french debate and tomorrow's in english
could prove critical on the stage
tonight justin trudeau aaron o'toole
jugmeet singh eve francois blanchette
and anamy paul maxine bernier of the
people's party was not invited
organizers say his party did not meet
the criteria
we'll have more on what to watch for in
a moment but first eric sorenson with
tonight's top story on where the race
stands heading into the debate
he's not a runaway winner in this
election race but aaron o'toole and the
conservatives have staked out a narrow
lead that did not exist before the
campaign began a lead built on attacking
one man and one party mr trudeau
misleading people
and saying whatever he wants to say to
try and get reelected and justin trudeau
sees a clear and present danger for his
party o'toole and the conservatives you
have to be honest with canadians
but that's something that we're seeing
is increasingly difficult for mr o'toole
to do for months trudeau had the
advantage of dominating public life
during the pandemic but an election
campaign levels the playing field and
the conservative leader has gained
ground we've seen the conservative party
has broken out a bit the conservatives
are consolidating behind aaron o'toole
as the best chance
to beat justin trudeau and the liberal
party among decided voters ipsos finds
conservatives have moved three points
ahead of the liberals 35 to 32 with the
ndp further back at 21 but would a
narrow conservative lead translate into
victory on election night in the 2019
election the conservatives beat the
liberals by more than a full percentage
point in the popular vote and still lost
the conservatives 121 seats the liberals
157 seats 36 more seats so the
conservatives have to flip a lot of
ridings in order to win the
conservatives are now running even with
the liberals in ontario and could flip
seats north of toronto then there's
quebec prone to massive swings the ndp's
orange wave in 2011. the liberals come
back in 2015 and the black quebecois
revival in 2019.
and the bq could shake up the race again
ipso says the bq has caught up with the
liberals in quebec and the conservatives
are third but doing better than before
the ndp is lagging we've seen that the
approach of mr trudeau has failed for
the ndp the liberals are also the target
[Music]
the new democrats are running first in
bc but in many ridings in the country
they could take votes away from the
liberals where conservatives could win
in order to
to consolidate the progressive vote the
liberals have to get some of those ndp
voters to move back there seems to be a
little bit of a wobble right now on the
ndp side
the liberal train is also a little
wobbly in a race that has become close
and unpredictable but one original
destination for the liberals a majority
government is an end point that is
looking increasingly distant eric
sorensen global news toronto
that is where the race is at right now
but there are still 12 days until the
election and a lot can happen in that
time for more on the party strategies
for tonight's debate let's bring in
michael couture in gatineau quebec mike
this has been a big gamble for justin
trudeau calling this election is he in a
political fight for his career in his
home province yeah he really is robin
when you consider that there are 78
seats up for grabs in the province of
quebec and that's what a lot of this
debate will be speaking to that province
and those voters trying to convince them
to vote for each of these party leaders
expect a combative trudeau
that is what we saw in the te veya
debate that there's a french first
french language debate that we saw last
week but at the same time this is a
delicate dance for him he also has to
look prime ministerial while taking
shots at others who are gaining on him
especially in quebec expect him to name
a lot of his attacks at eve francois
blachett and for him to return in kind
as eric mentioned we saw the rise of the
black quebecois in the last election and
the party's popularity appears to be
increasing this time around is tonight
going to be a showdown between e
francois blanchette and trudeau
yeah it really will be those are sort of
the two main on the card here uh expect
lanchette to continue his attacks on
trudeau for calling this election he
said and he continues to say look the
black quebecois was more than happy to
work with the liberals and continue to
make parliament function and why did mr
trudeau decide that he needed an
election trudeau will respond
by saying that look the block quebecois
is simply a protest party in quebec and
they really don't get a lot done and
they just like to complain a lot
obviously that's not how voters look at
it when you consider what the seat
totals were during the last election but
those are the two main ones on this
fight card tonight
and finally what's the strategy going to
be for the conservative and ndp leaders
to try to score political points
yeah for aaron o'toole it really does
seem like it's sort of steady as she
goes make sure that he proves that he is
a viable option he will have questions
to answer one of the big ones that the
block leader eve francois blanchett will
be throwing at him is specifically
around the daycare deals
that trudeau did ink with a lot of the
provinces including quebec what will he
do with that six billion dollar deal for
daycare in quebec that was supposed to
be guaranteed no strings attached money
he is not answering that question gun
control is also a big issue in quebec
and that is something that we've seen
o'toole
flounder a little bit on and why did he
flip-flop on it and why did he have that
amendment to his platform as for singh
keep in mind that he needs to make some
sort of a splash here in the last debate
the teve debate he really seemed like he
was on the sidelines the people in the
ndp camp were saying look you have to
understand french is his third language
behind english and punjabi but by the
same token he does want to have some
sort of an impact you know potentially a
2011 orange wave in quebec which does
seem relatively out of reach but he will
try and focus his attacks not only on
trudeau but also on e francois
blanchette
mike likature and get no queck thanks
mike and you can watch tonight's french
debate online at globalnews.ca live
coverage begins at 8 pm eastern
the conservatives are finally revealing
the cost of their campaign promises they
released their platform in the first
days of the campaign but the tories
faced growing pressure to show an
item-by-item price tag for all their
proposals and late this afternoon they
did our chief political correspondent
david aiken has been crunching the
numbers david
well robin the conservatives released
this casting in a bit of an odd way via
email and a technical briefing
conference call just two hours before
tonight's bait and
leader aaron o'toole he was not
available he did not speak about it or
take questions about it now only the
conservatives and the liberals have
released a costed platform so far we're
still waiting for the ndp so we can put
those two side by side the liberals plan
78 billion dollars in new spending
including an extra 13 billion dollars in
spending this year the conservatives
have a plan to spend an extra 51 billion
dollars over five years but they will
spend an extra 30 billion dollars this
year now the latest deficit forecast for
this year comes in around 138 billion
dollars under the liberal plan the
deficit would be 19 billion dollars
bigger than that or 157 billion
and the red ink would really flow with
the conservatives their plan would have
the deficit grow by 30 billion dollars
this year to come in at 168 billion
dollars now the conservatives say the
deficit in their plan falls to 25
billion dollars by 2026. the liberals
say their plan has the deficit at 32
billion dollars by then
one big difference the liberals tabled
no plan to balance the budget and the
conservatives say the budget will
balance in a decade now the tories say
they will not have to cut anything
instead the budget will balance because
the government will enjoy revenues from
an economy that is growing much more
rapidly than forecasters like the
parliamentary budget office or the bank
of canada are predicting most economic
analysts anticipate our economy to grow
by an average of 1.7 per year over the
next decade the tories are banking on
nearly twice that three percent a year
and that introduces a high level of
uncertainty we would want you to plan on
something that you have a more a greater
likelihood that you can count on it
because if the money doesn't show up and
you spent it either through a tax
expenditure or a program expenditure
then what so while the liberals will
introduce new taxes mostly on the
wealthy and on banks there are no new
taxes from the conservatives because the
conservatives are banking solely on
economic growth to find the money for
their programs in other words the
conservatives believe you guessed it
the budget will balance itself robin
david aiken in ottawa thanks david our
coverage of the campaign includes a big
road trip across canada and tomorrow
global national is broadcasting from the
maritimes donna friesen joins us now
from there hi donna
hi there robin we are in cape breton
nova scotia stunned by the beauty here
the liberals won 10 of the 11 seats in
nova scotia in 2019 and if support for
them is softening we'll begin to see the
first signs of that on election night
here in nova scotia we're talking
politics health care housing
affordability and we'll have an amazing
story about the connection between the
man who invented the telephone and the
first flight of an airplane here in
canada that's tomorrow global national
from cape breton
robin all right thanks donna and from
nova scotia global national will head to
quebec city and brampton ontario just
ahead of election night
turning to the pandemic nova scotia is
inching closer to getting back to normal
the province will move into phase five
of its reopening plan on september 15th
it means lifting all restrictions on
masking physical distancing and
gatherings both indoor and outdoor but
border measures will stay in place
anyone entering from outside nova scotia
newfoundland and p.i
who is not fully vaccinated will
continue to be required to isolate and
be tested
and starting october 4th nova scotia
will require proof of full vaccination
for people 12 and older to access
non-essential services and activities
that includes dining out and fitness
facilities nearly 72 percent of eligible
nova scotians are fully vaccinated new
public health restrictions are in effect
in parts of the northwest territories to
help curb an outbreak in its homeless
population the measures affect the
capital and three other communities
outdoor gatherings are restricted to 50
people indoor gatherings to 25. the
order is in effect for 14 days at least
19 people are infected with covid19 10
healthcare and support workers have also
tested positive
the territory's chief public health
officer is strongly recommending against
non-essential travel in and out of the
communities impacted one of the biggest
trials in the history of france is
underway 20 men are accused of
participating in the 2015 paris attacks
that have become known as francis 9 11.
130 people were killed and hundreds
injured the trial is expected to be the
longest ever set to last nine months the
judge will hear from close to 1800
witnesses and victims more than 300
lawyers are involved it's all happening
in a specially constructed courtroom in
paris that cost about 15 million to
build here's mike armstrong with a look
at the long-awaited trial and its
eventful first day
as painful as the trial will be
survivors turned up at the paris
courthouse hoping for answers they may
have lived through the attack but they
want to understand it
at last we are here this survivor says
this will help us to move on
it's been nearly six years since a
series of synchronized attacks november
13 2015. gunmen with suicide vests
stormed the bataclan concert hall six
bars and restaurants as well as a soccer
stadium during a match
so-called islamic state would claim
responsibility
130 people were killed
the french justice minister says that
day plunged all of france into horror
and that the french justice system must
now stand up
well that is happening in a specially
built and massive courtroom it was
actually constructed in the foyer of a
courthouse that dates back to the 14th
century
20 men are on trial 14 in person 6 in
absentia they're believed to be dead but
it can't be confirmed
now most of the men are accused of
playing a role in organizing the attacks
but not all
salah abdel slam is believed to have
been one of the gunmen but his explosive
vest never detonated whether it was a
malfunction or nerves only he knows
abdel slam escaped and was eventually
arrested in belgium after four months on
the run in court for day one he was the
most aggressive and vocal of the accused
when the judge asked his occupation he
said he had left all professions to
become a soldier of the islamic state
the judge responded with a joke saying
basically he'd heard it was an interim
position abdul salaam would go on to say
he was being treated like a dog and
ranted until his microphone was cut off
bataclan survivor thierry malee says he
was surprised by how much seeing
abdullah in person hit him but that he's
not scared and will face him in court
now the high profile of this trial has
the country on high alert and it's
likely to last a verdict isn't expected
until late may of next year mike
armstrong global news
a russian government minister who once
served in president vladimir putin's
security detail has died in the arctic
while trying to save the life of a film
director you have jenny zinechev headed
the high profile emergencies ministry
since 2018. the ministry says the
55-year-old died during a training
exercise the exact circumstances of his
death remain unclear officials say he
jumped from a cliff in an apparent
rescue attempt
ferocious storms tear through parts of
southwestern ontario coming up the trail
of damage people are now forced to clean
up plus powerful goals america's plan to
rely on solar energy and a towering
figure of racism removed
this is a look at the debris that was
strewn about at a farm in lucknow
ontario just north of goderich residents
are spending the day cleaning up
yesterday's severe storms moved through
parts of southern ontario prompting
environment canada to issue tornado
warnings for some areas
god those sparks are getting on the car
now
one toronto family woke up to this a
tree branch had fallen on a power line
the line then hit their car and sparked
a fire luckily no one was injured
i was quite worried last night to be
honest that there may be an ex an
explosion or something like that because
there was a lot of water out here
and then with the
the flame coming off the the wire
who knows what could have happened
hydro one says power has been restored
to more than 65 000 customers affected
by last night's storm crews continue to
work on other hard-hit areas
particularly along the shore of lake
huron
in mexico at least one person was killed
when a powerful earthquake struck near
acapulco last night
the magnitude 7 quake was felt hundreds
of miles away in mexico city it struck
just before 9 p.m and nearly 100
aftershocks were reported before dawn
the quake triggered widespread blackouts
landslides and several gas leaks no
major damage to buildings has been
reported
solar strategies still ahead the bright
plan for renewable energy in the u.s
one of america's largest confederate
monuments has come down the six-meter
bronze statue of general robert e lee
was removed from a pedestal in virginia
it overlooked the capitol for more than
a century but in recent years had become
a target of protesters looking to remove
symbols of racism the monument was
broken into pieces which will be put
into storage the graffiti covered
pedestal will stay for now
the biden administration has released an
ambitious renewable energy plan a new
report from the u.s department of energy
shows that by 2035 solar energy has the
potential to power 40 percent of
america's electricity and employ as many
as 1.5 million people without raising
electricity costs for consumers that
goal is contingent on congress passing
legislation that prioritizes and
supports renewable energy as well as the
widespread adoption of solar power it
currently accounts for about three
percent of the u.s electricity supply
britney spears is another step closer to
taking full control of her life in an
unexpected move her father filed to end
the court-ordered conservatorship that
has managed the singer's life and money
for 13 years the 39-year-old has tried
to remove her father from her case twice
in the last two years claiming that her
conservatorship was abusive jamie spears
took over his daughter's affairs after
she went through a mental health crisis
in 2008. he denies any allegations of
abuse and says he only wants what's best
for his daughter the decision now rests
with a judge and that is global national
for this wednesday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is near lord minster
saskatchewan thank you for watching and
be sure to tune in tomorrow when donna
friesen will broadcast from vedeck nova
scotia and i'll see you again this
weekend have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]